why do you think that Chris Brown was
canceled for the Rihanna situation but
but cardi B wasn't when she publicly
admitted to drugging and robbing men do
you think there's a bit of a double
standard yeah 100 shouldn't have done
that but he also shouldn't have used his
Force against her he's back now but I'm
saying cardi B never left like he had to
go away for a couple years
um to be honest with you I think there's
a difference between being physically
violent and taking men's money like what
if what if it was reverse if a guy was
drugging and robbing women not touching
them just drugging their models yeah
it's kind of a double standard right
but in the same breath there's a
difference between I personally believe
like a woman you know isn't as strong as
a man